this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the reaction
people citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for the midseason finale of invincible Aaron
I love filming with you post working out get a
be in shorts and be smelly cuz it makes me feel
Invincible how are you the real Aaron Alexander
oh I'm doing so well the real Greg Alba it's the
Greg Al are you real are you authentic no you're
fake very fake everything I say I like here it is
just a play Kate to all of you and I've been doing
it for a how long 10 years I've been lying for 10
years lying for 10 whole years strange comedy
today anyway guys leave a like on this video
be sure to uh check us out on patreon so you can
catch the full in through action watch song where
you sync up with your own copy of invincible thank
you to all who have joined we also cover several
things over there exclusively with highlights and
watch Longs included let's do it paranoid about
that YouTube intro yeah do you think like people
will think I'm being serious no thank God yes oh
[__] really yeah they're going to they're going
to stop watching a [__] you're going to lose
all 1 million subscribers he's not authentic it's
not real I mean by now they should know a damn it
it's been a while it's been a while you'll better
start with that okay find out what he's been up
to that senseless
oh oh we're going to see exactly where he
flew to yeah it looks like it so exciting
o I just got nipple chills I stepped
in an man the melancholic tone of this
season seriously now we see the effects
of what omim man's actions had on him
as sleep beneath the gold oh wa W he
flew for a long time oh man learn to
serve damn has he really changed holy [__] cuz
he failed his mission he can't go back
to the vites yeah it's just a lost soul
now a literal space wander this is beautiful damn
right space Nomad this is like the Barbie and Ken
Montage exactly exactly the same the
center the center of the world center
of the world and he's just right
there in the very center of this
planet oh and a black hole
okay okay this makes sense
how they came to to come together he saved them
him being on a different side of the
Galaxy I wonder how much time has passed
for him versus how much P time has passed
on Earth what makes five to seven business
days that's how long it takes
for a character Arc to come to
completion looks tired I will conquer you I don't
know who you are but we owe you our lives won't
you stay tell us your name where you come from
well I like the beard yeah it looks good with
it hello son love how he shaved
it back into a mustache hug him
I think they're going to hug I predict a
hug yeah like he's going to
Flinch I missed you that's truly conflicting
feelings yeah thin told me that they needed my
help It's Complicated come with me and no why
would you lie to me again you killed thousands
of people why would you think I'd ever want to see
you again well you did hu him I can't believe you
put them up to this made them lie to me too just
listen I don't have to listen to anything you say
I made a mistake that's a little one a mistake
yeah son no you don't get to call me that anymore
oo you could have started with I'm sorry is is
going to say it I'm not sorry I regret nothing
you whoa to your father I'll get you a ship home
but there's something you need to see first no
noot wasn't lying to you I don't care I'm on edge
5 minutes for them not you play Mark the Montage
of you traveling show him the beard the beard
will change his mind they asked me to be their
Emperor Emperor conqueror what's the difference
I mean this is more of a benevolent type of
ruling oh my God my husband's told me
so much about Anda what the is going on
wait who's the voice actress of her I'm
surprised you're married to Mom I can't
go back to Earth Mark the life I had there is
over no but you're the real star of the show
super glad you got to show me how great
your life is without us that's not what
I wanted to show you you could have given
a heads up about the whole tongue and the
bug thing pretty uncool brother how's that
math this is your little brother you got to
be you got to be Invincible
kidding strange title smash on that right
oh poor Debbie little does she know Nolan
is with a bug person and has moved on it's a a
purple baby thank God that bug turned out more
human than bug what's the color breeding on
that wow this is just a depressing composed
Montage episode I hope somebody edits The omn Man
flying with her walking it's interesting to do a
mirroring why me you could have taken Earth
whenever you wanted why did you marry me her feet
must be hurting so bad have so many steps on that
Fitbit you weren't real Mark and you almost took
him too I never knew you at all I never even knew
You Man The Voice work on her is great this season
I really feel like I'm watching a full-fledged
performance yeah know she's putting her all into
it the world of the living not this time I
remember the machine machine the explosion
of course you do you have all of my memories my
experiences because I'm the Clone yep there you
go we know exactly who's the original and who's
the inferior he turned into too face Debbie
it's it's Donald you're not the real Donald my
Donald died he was my favorite character last
season oh great now he's going to have
all the extra ST dread too oh I wonder
if they Ed the cloning technology from
uh the molder twins oh that would make
sense this is old glasses yeah but
why him what's so special about
him all in all those glasses
managed to survive that Rubble
pretty indestructible a new wife a kid
you just replaced us except you know bugs
I didn't replace you Mark or your mother I was
lost when I left Earth I found these people I
saved lives it was like I had a purpose again I
liked being a hero we're only allowed to procreate
with genetically similar species humans for
example look at you you are a viltrumite in
almost every way oh my God he's going to have to
protect him by now VTR knows I've left my post
and they'll find this planet and and when they do
they'll see your brother as inferior and kill him
well why don't you leave the planet omn man I
can't stop them alone but we can stop them whoa
what a turn of events your brother and all these
people will die without our help you're the reason
they're in danger you signed their death warrant
not me and now I'm asking you to help me save them
you did kind of do go there knowing that this is
a possibility omn man how can I help I couldn't
even beat you we can start training right away oh
my God a different meting this is so crazy I love
it the anxiety of the situation what was
that oh it could be the three that went
after Allen oh looks like y sure enough three
already no time to train they're here it's too
late filite soldiers Mark get Anda and your
brother to safety where Andressa will show
you go there's no time I don't know if I would
acknowledge that kid as my brother you don't
know him but like what Technic technically is
your brother squash him like all the bugy is
should have packed your bags better robot
we seen this dude in a while yeah he's in
the first episode put robot's thing back and I
won't beat the living [__] out of you how's
that for a deal you want this back come and get
it you know she could whoop your ass without even
trying THX and lifespans aren't like humans
only one of your years seriously it's never
seem short to me damn I didn't knowingly try to
replace your mother your father saved my life at
first it was hard to know him he was so hurt
so closed off after what happened on Earth so
hot so it's true great Nolan fathered a
child with an earthwoman Steve Harvey If
you fight well we may allow you to join
the Empire if not you'll die maybe I
wasn't stay away from my children
lcan hey I got full oh my
God dud save him save him
protect you've disarmed your
people [__] he's evenly
matched you deserve death who he just
do that oh my God oh my God yeah that's
crazy Humanity really changed him after
slaughtering everyone and having a kid
yeah genocide will do that to you genocide you
Calla shooting shooting I guess when your arm's
a gun you really only have one trick it's a good
trick not tonight it is it I'm curious why this
is one of the plot lines yeah right I feel like
she hasn't got as much to do this season I mean
we are seeing her emotions come out she is
taking out a lot of anger on his person true
when she could end it very quickly if she
wanted to we're not done yet not by a long
shot oh no that your powers
cause problems when collateral
damage oh no no yes ouch
ouch
whoa
I mean they they got to be dead can she
resurrect people I wouldn't be surprised
if she can if she can create life she can
Restore Life are they okay please please
just help them got to be more responsible
with your powers would you say the same
thing if that was a man absolutely not cuz I'm
a raging sexist Debbie are you home oh is that
art can I come come in it is you okay I'm fine
I just I'm not fine fine usually means you're
not I always thought you were the strong one
to handle your life the way you did a that's
sweet no one has superpowers he's indestructible
that's not strength yeah the real reason we're
all still alive and not slaves that is true
Nolan was always off fighting something and
you made things work without him now it's just
official you don't need the bum you never did oh
wow art I am glad you showed up this season for
that one scene cuz that is some really making a
difference run now this is horrifying
oh no you guys did a bang up job
Dad Dad uh-oh uh-oh what why do I care
about them they were weak short-lived
barely a species oh no I'm not supposed
to feel this way oh no he's crying this
is how you should have felt on Earth doesn't
know what to do with all these emotions use
those emotions Nolan I'll kill you for what
you did to these people then do it that was
going to be awesome I really hope Nolan
doesn't die can you imagine I don't think
they're going to kill him here because
you're Nolan's son I'll make this quick
oh did the Judo
Chop Chop his arm off she has a
blade on the end of her on the
end of her hair that's crazy there
I promised I'd make it quick oh
[__] Mark what are you doing she's tearing you
apart she's trying to kill you Mark if you're
not trying to kill her you're going to die
don't think act you need to fight like a
Vite God oh my God we're all dead you me
your brother and every single thren on this
planet they'll probably go to earth right
after to be a hero he has to
embrace his ultimate vulture
you don't need to fight like a hero fight like a a
warrior grab it play against yes break those limbs
come on yes yes oh man so good his strength has
always come in wanting to fight for something
more meaningful more than himself use that rage
too
finally oo oh oh oh what a bone
crunching like look at that call book wa
great editing my God yeah great editing
oh oh oh oh damn throwback do that win it
om man's going to do it for him he's going
have in him I know he's not dead but like you
held back you held back do you regret scre you
dead going to rip her scalp off
rip it oh oh my God that's a
cross mark you did it are you okay no don't
worry it's over is your guard down why is your
guard why is your guard down
next time you kill somebody
make sure they're dead holding his
guts no it can't be he didn't kill him could
be paralyzed though I don't want Nolan's book
money the survivors in Chicago need it
more than I do and if you can't find a
way to get it to them I will Savage Planet
Savage beasts if you change your mind I
won't C's not a bad guy I don't always treats
him like he's the enemy oh my God oh my God are
they getting they both getting taken possibly he
might be taking him to Vite no way is he going to
have to rescue his pops dad Mark don't forget
the good I did wow my books read my books Mark
read my books I'm going to take Invincible
with them is there a clue in there possibly
oh now she's getting rid of them
seems like it where can you get a
copy the man with an invincible
gun or dude oh no she gets depressing
Montage why do you keep trying to have
a relationship with him they're just the
worst cuz the that guilt's inherit to her
her dad's voice is ingrained her like cuz
she thinks that she is bad are you a cyborg he
was bleeding he was not what is it bent oh it
is what does the bent mean I think it means he's
part robot my name is General C you've survived
your first true battle and proven yourself
worthy of your viltrumite heritage oh [__]
it oh your father will be executed and you will
return to Earth you will assume his mission and
prepare the planet for our rule oh my God is
that the voice of Darth blood you can kill a
few humans to convince them to capitulate or
we will kill Millions if we arrive to find you
or your planet still defiant against us that
is the beginning of The Season's coming full
circle yeah and unlike your father we do not
change our minds oh my God he's being forced
to become a vulture M oh this is this is insane
this is a crazy episode man this is really crazy
how he going to get back home too he's got a
bunch of ships to choose from he still doesn't
know the way yeah we got to go back to the merer
twins we got to see our uh the black dude too the
multi-dimensional guy with his big ass brain
messy wiring sloppy welding obviously the work
of a clone why stop at one idiot clone when I
can have so many more oh yeah it's true I hope
one of you is better in the kitchen that's
why he wanted to establish this himself as
original I poisoned him when it's not laced with
a modified MotoX that is I just love how they
just are always willing to kill off each other
sometimes things are the way they are for a good
reason there's way more F bombs this episode
than ever oh totally feel like neither of them
were ever the original cuz they die so much
they never know oh yeah yeah none of them are
no original that was a gnarly gnarly episode
that was really good a lot of I think it's
the most action we've seen though all season two
probably trying to see if we see the other cast
members names see here oh most brutal they to
wait a whole five four months before the next
one or a few months yeah damn let's see hold on
hold on yeah okay yeah Clancy Brown Clancy Brown
played um dark blood and and he's also playing
Craig General Craig Clancy Brown get that work
he's one of the best voice actors yeah wait a
minute though wait a minute though I think I
think it's important that when having to navigate
around you don't want your communication to get
interfered via satellite you know yeah and
that's why I have a very important message
I got to convey to the audience think thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's right
years so whenever want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's more
to it than that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum shutting down my
internet and contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my new
laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I was
paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com reex and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to expressvpn.com
reject to learn more thank you again all right
guys well yes thank you for sponsoring this
video and um man Aaron please what what did
you think about out this episode obviously the big
talking point is going to be the Muller twins of
course the biggest part of this episode the most
controversial part the most exciting part no um
this episode was great this episode was really
good uh we got a lot of stuff with omn man which
was unexpected to see the complexity of where
he's been since we started this the season yeah
man I was I was really enthralled by everything
happening on that front and because especially
with you know him finding this species that is
made of bugs and the the dichotomy I guess or the
difference in the fact that he viewed his wife
as a pet someone that was uh of human descent
was something that he could uh mix with have
intercourse with sexual relations but these bug
people have a shorter span of life so the fact
that he's able to find humanity trying to sound
smart I'm formulating my thoughts damn it we're
getting from here to here so anyway he so he yeah
he's able to find humanity in something that was
that had such a short lifespan which I feel like
really shows the fact that he's grown because you
know you you see fly like normal house flies and
we know that they have such a short short lifespan
in them themselves so the fact that he's able to
do that kind of is like a representation of how
much he's grown because yeah plus he has a son
uh yeah there's a lot of really good stuff in here
from Donald realizing that he's not entirely human
to Al Adam Eve kind of realizing that or I guess
backtracking because she is listening to the voice
of her parents at least that's the implication
of it it because she has doubts about herself and
her abilities because her dad implanted that
thing that she's dangerous and her power she
can't be trusted which is kind of a sad like her
mental Kryptonite to the fact that you know she's
essentially God but she has all these internalized
beliefs from her her abusive parents that she
can't fully come into her own as a powerful uh
being now we got some stuff with what I guess
we had a little bit of the stuff with the Mark's
friends but that wasn't really much of the story
but yeah I I like the episode a lot uh I think
we have a really big cast this season so we have
to like really spread out everything like Adam Eve
wasn't even in the last episode none of the people
from the the main team were part of this episode
either so I don't know this we got half of a
season worth of stuff yeah it's a great mid-season
finale though great midseason finale fin Al it's a
great Mak you want to come back and see what
unfolds yeah definitely the stakes are high
stakes are high high stakes high stakes value high
stakes high stakes rare Stakes uh but yeah I liked
it a lot I think one of the hardest parts about
writing is truly knowing how to embrace the gray
of a situation it's really easy to acknowledge the
gray but more often than not I think um a writer
often makes a choice of not sitting there and
ultimately choosing a path between somewhere that
lean a little more black and white I think that's
one of the hardest parts when you're working with
screen time versus real life um that's where the
har partk can come in that's one thing I'm really
respecting about this season in particular is
they truly let you sit with the gray you know even
right from EV every every debate and argument that
was acknowledged I think they would really explore
the arena and the vast array of the thoughts and
emotions that would you know rise to the surface
on such a unique unique problem like with Mark of
he hugs his dad and it's like no go after yourself
and why do you want me no this it's like that that
pingpong battle in between and then even seeing
like the kid and like why should I care but but
it's it's not her fault you know like the constant
back and forth even with Adam Eve I think like uh
I think it might be a little bit more layered in
the sense of there's so much wrong about the way
her parents treat her she knows that there's so
many psychologically abusive sides especially on
the side of her dad yeah however there might be a
layer there where you might be a little bit right
about hey you are not God you are not someone who
has all the answers and maybe if you don't keep
acting like you know everything you might create a
better sense of awareness on when you're handling
certain situations because she has made mistakes
from thinking she knows best you know and that's
that's part of what I mean by that gray of it
is there can be the acknowledgement like he is a
messed up guy he is he does treat her bad there's
also this one quality though that he might be
right about you know like like there can be these
multiple layers like one of my favorite moments
is like Mark saying Mark just telling the bug
mom um I I know none of this is not is your fault
none of this is your fault but it still hurts and
that's what I I think that is probably the perfect
encapsulation of what I mean by the gray you know
and I just love that about what they're doing here
uh from Debbie that Debbie is a great example of
that too of the The Crib like I hate you so much
you did all this wrong why do I miss you though
you know why what like you can have both you can
have these coexisting feelings and the show lets
those those colors coexist together versus just
choosing one side eventually a character has
to choose a path that's what we do in life we we
feel out everything but we have to make a choice
regardless and we have to move on ahead uh whether
that be something that's bad for us or good for
us we make a choice and that's what they're doing
with their characters like they they just let them
see all this this and I like there I think there's
it's really hard to find a show that does that or
a movie like it's way harder with a movie a movies
such a shorter runtime you have to tell something
a lot more you know in a more specific time frame
and but for a show like this is this is true this
true character exploration this true character
driven narrative while giving you like awesome
visuals and great fight scenes and you know like
superhero complexities and stuff but this is so
much more human than a lot of shows that are about
just human beings you know and I I think this is
a this is probably my favorite just because of
that front and willingness uh it it is probably
my favorite superhero show I think we've seen
all year yeah I'd have to agree with that yeah
no yeah kind of to build off what you were saying
about the the gray the fact that D with Nolan too
with Nolan too yeah cuz he's cuz he like choked
his son like crying yeah cuz he he feels like why
do I feel things and yeah it's no man it's just
it's it's really interesting because we you know
we we're in this age of of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right and so sexist Jesus no in the no
we're we're the we're the age of Marvel right
and I feel like there is such an apprehension
towards having people that are in emotional
gr areas because they want to make things as
likable as possible but I think by not trying to
make something that that's widely appealing and
showing something that's gray showing something
that's more human and more complicated I think
that endear us to the characters we're watching
more because we see elements of ourselves within
that because humans are complicated you know
humans do have multifaceted sometimes conflicting
desires and I think it's important that we're
having that represented in the show and I like
the fact that this is something that is not only
complex but it's also authentically comic Booky
as well because we're seeing weird alien stuff
we're seeing clones we're seeing demons you know
but it's very much rooted in that human conflict
and all the performances really show up to play
as well you know we don't it doesn't come off as
like this heightened version of what what acting
is you know it feels very much in spite of the
fact that it's animated like these performers are
giving their all showing that Nuance within those
performances which I think is is great and yeah I
I firmly agree that this is one of the the best
shows not only comic book shows best shows that
have been on this year yeah and I I think they
take advantage of the fact that it's an animated
medium and in in all the right ways I think uh I
I really love this this series a lot and I think
I think the the way they've Amplified this season
with that's it's so strange they got a lot going
on but I'm like I I feel like they're not in a
rush to wrap it all even when it comes back to
finish off season 2 they're not in a rush to like
end it down season two you know like I'm like yeah
let's stick around for the Long Haul because
this exploration is is great because this is
is more than just World building which they do you
know they they've opened the Multiverse and stuff
and and and I love how they're not bogged down by
excitement like it is so melancholic it's so sad
like it's sad but it's also going to be funny the
great I think they're really they it surprises me
that uh of how this show continues to surprise me
uh in that regard because this season especially
has doubled down on existentialism Consciousness
uh all these different things that you cannot
really spew about while you're in the middle of
a reaction so you make some stupid joke one more
often the dumb thoughts that pop into our heads
we not try to be dumb we were just dumb in the
moment and then we think about it after you know
what process you know our our complex thoughts but
I mean to get some of the main things out of the
way like uh om yeah omn man has has been a a nice
surprise like I I believe again like they didn't
just try slingshotting him until like he's a hero
now you know like I love when he choked Mark and
he's and it's just he's watching the devastation
and any other show would just have you tease
with the rage but the last thing you're going
to do is have him choke his own kid like the
the fight of of feeling hurt yeah you know the
pain of the loss of love that like the compassion
weighing against your heart and and your fighting
literally the pH most physical representation of
fighting against it by your own flesh and blood uh
was was a powerful moment I was like damn this is
heartbreaking and uh even is pleading at the end
and to get these other vites were wow we' got like
we thought omn man was bad right what the hell we
have on our hands now you know a whole planet of
people that are survival of the fittest and like
we are the top race and also the fact at the end
that you know Mark has been wrestling all season
long with am I like my dad like no I need to prove
I'm not like my dad in this this overwhelming
guilt that he needs to be the best hero that he
can be but that need to be hero was originally
inspired by the fact that he looked up to his
dad like to such a great degree and now he's
threatened by his dadge Heritage to be the thing
that he fears most to be the thing that he's most
insecure about and yeah I'm really wondering how
that's going to come into play because yeah if he
doesn't they're going to come they're going to ks
to fill his dad's role so maybe he's gonna find a
way to beat the vill MS I don't know I don't know
may that because that scene with Allen hasn't
happened yet as far as this show has shown us I
mean I hope Alan heels cuz from the last episode
it looks like he's going to die cuz uh Optimus
Prime is the mole so who knows I don't know that
a whole plot too that whole plot there's a lot
of plots a lot of plots happening but yeah it's
like a big expansive universe but damn they keep
it like whenever you cut to something you're not
thinking about what's going on over here right
like you're just that moment you're just in the
moment of what's Happening you know yeah and it's
not about like theories and all this other [__]
like you're just watching like like even like
I didn't really I like Donald last season but
I wasn't care about I wasn't like oh like oh
guy have a bummer he died because he was like
a likable personality right but what they're doing
here which is just all mainly tone based it's like
yeah this is compelling what you're watching this
guy go through like what is he who is this Donald
is this is the same doled ises he a resurrected is
he a robot and what does this say about again like
the existential themes this see like they like
the last episode dealt a lot with characters who
experience death over and over again you know yeah
and and and so I really I really love what they're
doing there and what they're doing with omn man
I think is really compelling stuff you can't kill
them off even if he gets killed off the comics you
can't kill him off he's the thing that brings in
the dollars he's the bread winner here how happy
to have him back yeah to see where his his mental
state is at now and what how is Mark GNA save
him is he going to save him like what's going
to happen there I I know like who would who would
ban with him right who would risk their neck to
save yeah who believe who' believe Mark that he's
changed if he's the person leading that charge to
save him like the and to call the show Invincible
he has to go through like the most insane
insurmountable obstacles in the most isolating
types of scenarios in order to gain that P that
that image of invincibility you know in order to
really gained that uh that title H in the most
apt way so I I I'm so fascinated by what direction
we're going and so I think for a mid-season finale
it does feel like there's so much that's been set
up and so much has been done that even though yeah
I do feel like we didn't watch Eight Episodes I
still feel like I got like a full meal yeah solid
experience filling experience normally sometimes
these midseason final like H seems like we were
just kind of like what's happening oh okay now we
got to go Cliffhanger I'm like no but they still
told like a solid package oh yeah in this part
one yeah uh I loved it I really loved it a lot
and and yeah what they did with Debbie's growth
is great and then like even art like again it's
about quality and versus quantity art shows
up for one scene be like yo I got some troops
to drop to you I'm like goddamn right yeah but
every there'd be more dead people if it wasn't
for Debbie and stilling some good at him yeah
yeah cuz she yeah she was she's the heart you
know she she held him at Bay until markk was able
to find the strength within and showing like no
I do have actual strength yeah and it's true
she does uh I just took the oldest whitest guy
and this little soul patch over here um phenomenal
stuff phenomenal stuff all around great Voice work
and uh good violence again missed the violence
yeah first two episodes were good but I think
these last two episodes are great yeah yeah
the first the first two were good and I really
appreciate what they were doing um but you know
you have to kind of sit it through like you can't
you can't have the last two without the first two
yeah you a natural buildup aggressive show should
yeah yeah oh wow guys what did you think about
these two man I thought I I thought it was these
were excellent and again this just solidifies
is this depending on whenever this show ends
which I imagine wouldn't be for a while this
could go down as like the best superhero show
oh yeah totally I know some people can't just
give it to that only because it's animated and
not liveaction but [__] the writing is so much
better superb than so many superhero shows yeah
I mean the the boys is great too but I think
that this really there's a sense of cynicism to
the boys that's kind of like making fun of comic
book tropes in like in media but I think this is
very sincere in its love of comic books while
also having a self-awareness that it's a comic
book exactly yeah yeah couldn't said it better
myself yeah well we complet completed each other's
sandwiches I honestly don't remember
what the rest of that sentence
was we did it you have a cough going on nope nope
I'm healthy you got the you got Theona nope you
sure want we do a test on camera play it out
in real time let's do it you how terrible of
a human being you would look you want to stick
on my nose make out after yep full tongue just
like omn man the [__] like this how we run
the rejects around here would would you dip
me or would I dip you for like our our on screen
kiss is that how that work you you want to like
I dip you you of course th% dip you I have longer
hair so you know just like like that just look at
our physical statures it makes more sense that
I dip you exactly you look like manlier cuz I'm
like I'm larger than so he just like oh yeah
so it makes sense that I be the one to dip you
exactly breaking stereotypes here
yeah anyway after a very serious
conversation and the classic style Aaron
happy to be covering this with you my
friend was this the first show we covered
or was it umbrella AC I think was Umbrella
Academy the first Umbrella Academy was the
first one we did yeah and then we did this
one after yeah is this one after yeah cuz
I think we did Umbrella Academy 2020 this
is 2021 yep yeah that's how times we've
changed' changed times have changed it's
growth